In this video, we'll start looking at real-time lighting in Unreal Engine
and working with post-processing volumes.
An easy way we can start changing the rendering settings for our level
is by adding in a post-process volume.
This will allow us to create specific overrides
for rendering settings when we are within the volume
or we can also enable the checkbox for infinite extend
to apply these settings to the entire level
whether we're inside the volume or not.
The two things we're going to look at here
are the exposure settings and the bloom settings.
In my own personal experience, I find that the auto exposure
that is set by default in Unreal Engine
can make it a little difficult when trying to balance
all of your different lights and get a specific look
like evening or nighttime inside of your game.
And so by switching it to manual
and changing our exposure compensation,
we can get more of an evening look.
And then as well, we can affect the power of bloom
in order to make our stage pillars glow even brighter.
So let's take a look.
We can add a post-process volume quickly
from the add actor button up here
coming down to visual effects instead of volumes.
Click and drag our post-process volume into the level.
So it doesn't look like anything's happened.
Right now it still has all the same default configurations.
This is what we see around us.
And we're also outside of the box.
To give you an example of what this might look like,
we'll change our exposure compensation here to 0.1
when we are in our metering mode to manual.
Actually, we can just leave this at 1.
And so when we go in the box, very dark.
Sun's up there.
Out of the box, very bright.
So what if we want to see this, though,
throughout the entire level?
Like I mentioned a minute ago, we
can search for infinite extend, have that enabled,
and now the entire scene will be affected by these settings
that we apply here in the volume.
So I'm going to bring this up, though.
10, maybe 8.
And I also want to change our bloom,
which you were looking at up here,
and change the intensity of the bloom to 0.8.
And we'll see that the glow from our pillars
has gotten a little bit brighter.
I think we can also change our lighting here, too,
by working with the position of our sun.
And we can make our sun go a little bit down lower.
I think it's here we go.
Get some cool evening sky going on here.
Yeah, that'll be good.
And we can also change the intensity of our sun
here as well.
We want to see a little bit more of a afternoon light.
And I think maybe let's ramp up
the bloom a little bit more for today.
Let's process volume.
Let's put that to 1 or even 2.
We can see what that's doing a little more clearly.
We're unchecked versus checked.
A little subtle for now, but that's OK.
So now that we have our manual exposure set,
let's add in a few more lights
and tweak their settings in order to get the look
that we're going for inside of the scene.
So to add light actors,
once again, we can come here to our Add Actor button,
search for lights.
We already have a directional light in the scene
and it's recommended to not have more than one.
So instead, I'm going to add a spotlight
and we can see its cone coming down.
I'm going to add this spotlight
I think kind of off to the front over here.
We can angle it by pulling up our rotator gizmo.
I'm going to change its intensity to 12.
Let's try 20, 40, there we go.
Let's rotate it a little bit more.
I'm going to do an Alt drag off of it.
Come over to the other side,
be down a little more,
rotate it around, there we go.
It's looking a little bit more square on there.
We'll make this one a little cooler,
give ourselves kind of a three-point lighting setup.
We'll drag this one off over here,
also bring it down over this way,
bring it back around to face our dancer,
up, over,
and we can also,
let's maybe change our outer cone angle
and make it a little bit brighter or narrower
so we can really hone in on our character here.
Okay, I think that's looking pretty good.
Let's maybe bring up,
so obviously you can go all day fiddling around
with these settings.
We'll keep it a little more tight here,
that's zero, yeah, that's cool, awesome.
In the next video, we'll take a look at some of the
modeling tools in Unreal Engine
and how we can use them to modify the meshes in our project.